theorizing the science of nitpicking
deconstructing
and reconstructing plot lines however it
is not an all-powerful art it is
impossible to create a theory out of
nothing
if one wishes to gather evidence for a
theory all arguments of
it's just a movie bro must be thrown
aside
this is the law of of course this wasn't
what the creator intended but damn it
we're exploring it anyway
the basis of all theorizing in
accordance with this law there was a
taboo among theorists
anime anime theories are strictly
forbidden for what theory would not
anger the die hard fans perhaps a theory
calculating the worth of a human
soul that'll probably get people mad too
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the only show on youtube that can ruin
your childhood faster than a botched
attempt at bringing your dead mother
back to life
you know it's been a while since we last
talked about full metal alchemist and a
lot has changed in the world of anime
since we corrected edinault's
biochemistry homework
a brand new season of attack on titan
has come and gone my hero academia has
stolen our hearts and naruto
has a kid now apparently man life moves
fast i mean one moment you're in school
wearing a metal headband making hand
signs and running around with your hands
behind your back even though
scientifically speaking the drag that
creates would only make you slower and
the next your old buddy naruto is a dad
makes you feel kind of old doesn't it
makes you kind of worry about the
inevitability of death
well it's that kind of existential
crisis that makes a guy want to pursue
immortality
an anime has plenty of potential
solutions vampirism
wishing on the dragon balls but it's
full metal alchemist
brotherhood the 2009 reboot of full
metal alchemist that more closely
follows the story of the original comics
that has the solution to immortality
that i want to explore today
ladies and gentlemen of the internet
strap yourselves in because today
it is my goal to calculate the strength
of a human soul
and be warned because there are some
pretty intense spoilers for fma
brotherhood
up ahead nine different characters in
full metal alchemist brotherhood
are functionally immortal the seven
homunculi artificial humans named after
the seven deadly sins their creator
father and von hoenheim the dear old dad
of our two heroes edward and alphonse
elric
now all of these characters can and do
in fact
die in the series but only when someone
goes out of their way to kill them
and even then it takes a lot of effort
the homunculi are shown to be able to
regenerate their entire bodies
instantaneously and without anyone
trying to murder them it's implied that
they could live for hundreds maybe even
thousands of years
so what's the secret to their impossibly
long lives well
each of their bodies holds what's known
as a philosopher's stone
a magical item that amplifies an
alchemist's transmutation abilities the
elric brothers actually find out what it
takes to make one of these stones pretty
early on in the series
episode seven but the truth that they
uncover is pretty horrifying
the main ingredient for a philosopher's
stone
is human life in order to manufacture
even a single stone you have to make
multiple human sacrifices the
philosopher's stone
is people more specifically each
philosopher's stone is made from human
souls
sacrificed extracted and refined to
delicious red liquid throughout the
series we see the stone fuel to
homunculize superhuman physical
abilities and regenerative powers and
also allow for alchemical transmutations
that produce more matter than goes into
them
to put it another way those souls were
reduced to mere energy so what the
philosopher's stone is
essentially is a supercharged alchemist
battery running on human
souls and if we can figure out how much
raw energy that battery stores
we can figure out how much energy each
human soul contains and from there
calculate how many human souls it would
take to put a few extra 100 years on old
matpat's clock maybe then i'll finally
have time to watch all of one piece
to figure this out we're gonna need two
things one a way of comparing a
philosopher's stone to a real world
source of energy
and two a measure of exactly how many
human souls the stone contains
fortunately for us theorists fma
brotherhood gives us the chance to
calculate bulls in episode 19
one of the homunculi lust stabs colonel
roy mustang in the gut and leaves him
for dead
surprise surprise roy actually isn't
dead and sneaks up on her later burning
her to death with a broken lighter and a
transmutation circle carved into the
back of his own hand
she tries to fight back via repeated
regenerations but eventually succumbs to
the flames what a casual viewer might
see as one of the most exciting and
badass moments of the show
is the moment i see as the key to this
entire
theory as i established in my last
episode about fullmetal alchemist human
bodies in this fictional universe are
made of the same stuff as human bodies
in
our universe they give us the explicit
formula in the show and it matches
real life one for one so if we can
figure out how much energy is contained
within a human body we can extrapolate
from there how much energy it would take
lust to regenerate that body after
mustang serves it up extra crispy style
and based on how many times she gets
burned before being completely roasted
we can figure out exactly how much
energy is contained within her
philosopher's stone
then from there divide by the number of
souls in the stone and voila we have
calculated the amount of energy
one human soul contains isn't math great
so i'm going to put a brief pause on
this scene and hop over to figuring out
how many souls are in lust stone to
answer that question we need to look at
the source of the homunculi
father man who looks suspiciously like
the ulrich's own father von hoenheim the
reason for that resemblance is we learn
from the flashback in episode 40 is that
father was originally a homunculus made
from hohenheim's blood back in xerxes
xerxes is a legendary kingdom whose
population died mysteriously in a single
night 400 years before the start of the
series
and that little incident happened
because father decided to transmute the
entire country's population
to make two philosopher stones one for
himself and one to von hoenheim to repay
him for giving him life
and jeez does that ever make me feel
self-conscious about my thank you gifts
i mean
cards flowers apparently if i really
loved my mom i'd get her immortality at
the hands of countless screaming
tortured souls of a dead civilization
immortality the gift that keeps on
giving literally
well i might have spoken too soon
countless isn't the right word
here i mean i was worried that i'd have
to make estimates based on historical
precedence and census data and the few
images that we had of the nation of
xerxes but the anime actually did all
the counting for me
it took time but i managed to learn the
name of every last soul 536
3329 the people you trapped inside of me
which is impossible just by the way
dunbar's number
proposed by anthropologist robin dunbar
is the theoretical cognitive limit to
the number of people with whom a person
can maintain a stable relationship
other anthropologists have pegged this
average number to be around 300 based on
different factors but regardless of how
many it is it is a
far cry from 536
000 people there are limits to how much
information the human mind can hold
but i suppose that's not accounting for
magically enhanced soul-infused minds
and the show did help me by giving me a
hard number to work with so
i guess i can let it slide this one time
this time
anime this time
anyway his father himself declares in
the aftermath of the transmutation
the voices of all the people in this
country who were offered in exchange
for your immortality
well half of their lives were for me
actually
which clearly tells us that exactly the
same number of souls are trapped inside
father as are trapped inside hohnheim
now we know by watching the anime that
father created the seven homunculi by
extracting the seven deadly sins from
each of those five hundred thousand plus
souls contained within him it was all
part of a big effort to purge himself of
all his negative desires and emotions
but obviously he still has a lot of
those souls left inside i mean
after all he's using his own souls to
fuel the alchemy of every person in the
country
and he's shown to be much more powerful
than any of his children
if father purged himself of all those
souls vices that would obviously leave
their virtues going by the same biblical
principles just like there are seven
deadly sins pride
envy gluttony lust wrath greed and sloth
they're contrasted against the seven
heavenly virtues
faith hope charity fortitude justice
temperance and prudence
not nearly as fun or as exciting no
obviously every person is going to have
a different amount of each of those
traits but with a large enough sample
size and
i'd say 500 000 is certainly a large
enough size
they're likely to all even out at the
end so we can assume that father stone
is divided 14 ways across
seven sins and seven virtues and with
father keeping the virtues he has fifty
percent of the total souls
that means each homunculus contains
exactly one fourteenth of the souls that
father
started with clearly this guy was a bit
smarter than voldemort when it came to
dividing up his soul into seven vessels
as such we can conclude that lust's
philosopher's stone contains about 1
14th of those 536
329 souls or about 38
309.2 now back to the scene where she
dies
we can count that mustang lit her on
fire nine times before she completely
turns to ash
so that means each explosion is burning
through 38
309 divided by 9 or roughly 4
256 souls with each blast but now how do
we get to the energy contained in each
of those souls
well the answer lies in how she
regenerates at first glance you might
assume that the homunculi operate like
cell from dragon ball z who
true to his name can regenerate his
entire body from a single cell through
replication but that would make some
amount of sense the energy in the
philosopher's stone could be used as
fuel for rapid cell growth but it's not
consistent with other ways that we see
the stones used throughout the series
time and time again we see philosopher's
stones used by alchemist to add mass to
objects
and even change their very nature
turning things like wood into stone or
flowers into crystals new matter just
can't come out of nowhere that would
violate the laws of physics or in
fullmetal alchemist language it would
violate the law of equivalent exchange
to obtain something of equal value must
be lost
so what must be happening here is that
the energy inside of the stone is being
converted directly into physical matter
in accordance with einstein's theory of
mass energy equivalence now if you're
not familiar with the most
famous scientist ever well then hey
welcome you must be new to the theorist
family because i
talk about this guy a lot on your way
out make sure you hit that subscribe
button to transmute yourself from a
viewer to a subscriber that way you get
notified of all the other cool anime
related theories that i do on the
channel anyway even the loyalists of
theorists could probably do with a quick
refresher so aside from his cookie
haircut the thing that albert einstein
is best known for
is proving that matter and energy are
actually the same thing
einstein's most frequently quoted
formula e equals m c
squared is what allows us to convert
from one to the other it's
not unlike how alchemists change the
form of matter going based on the
formula the energy contained in an
object is equal to its mass or weight in
kilograms multiplied by the speed of
light in meters per second squared
now the speed of light is pretty darn
huge so this formula gives you some
pretty crazy big numbers and it's no
accident it takes an
insane amount of energy to hold the
atoms of an object together and when
that energy is released well
that is literally what a nuclear bomb is
since the philosopher's stone is using
alchemy to rebuild lust's body out of
pure soul energy
figuring out how much she expends to
regenerate is as simple as plugging half
her weight into the formula i say half
since only part of her body is getting
burned with each of mustang's blasts
that leaves us to calculate her weight
which honestly is pretty easy to piece
together
plus doesn't have an official weight but
her official height according to manga
charts is
5 feet 7 inches an average healthy
weight for a woman that size with a
medium frame is 140 pounds or 63
kilograms
and lust looks um she looks uh
she looks healthy to me so we'll go with
that for our estimates
plugging in 50 of that weight and then
solving the equation gives us an
energy equivalent of two million seven
hundred eighty six thousand
one hundred forty one tera joules now
that number probably doesn't mean a
whole lot to you so let me translate
that's the equivalent of about
12 large hydrogen bombs going off
and with that sense kim jong-un suddenly
decided to subscribe to the film
theorists go figure
to get the energy value of one soul we
just divide that by the number of souls
lust expends to regenerate
4256.6 which gives us 654
tera joules per soul which is the
equivalent of about 156
kilotons of tnt or about 10 times the
power of the bomb dropped on hiroshima
to put that in perspective based on the
rules of full metal alchemist
brotherhood you could use the power
contained in one soul to create an
explosion
big enough to destroy half of manhattan
one soul so in retrospect i guess i was
a little bit off in my last theory in
addition to all the component elements
of a human body they were missing the
elric brothers were apparently short a
few pounds of uranium in their
transmutation
circle which if you think about it would
have cost them an arm and a leg anyway
you get it cause cause edward is missing
an arm and a leg what's that supposed to
mean gee ed it's just an expression
there's no need to get
short with me damn it i told you before
don't tell me
it's too easy but all that math still
doesn't get us to the immortality that i
wanted to get at the beginning of this
episode
the energy of one soul obviously isn't
enough for eternal life and with 38
000 souls the homunculi still die pretty
easily all things considered
if we want to be immortal like hohenheim
and father we're gonna need the same
amount of energy that
they have to find the energy of all the
souls inside father we need to multiply
the energy of one soul by 536
329 which gives us the whopping number
of
351 exajoules
that is five times as much electricity
as the entire world generates in a
single year which is a lot of energy but
don't get me wrong it's still totally
attainable you'd only need about half
the world's uranium reserves
and you'd also have to figure out how
alchemy works too i guess but we'll
cross that bridge when we come to it so
there you have it loyal theorists we
have proven definitively the value of a
human soul
isn't some magical unquantifiable thing
but it's still way too rich for my
non-immortal blood so yes i'd start
building that dragon radar
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
cut
[Music]
you